I think most of us
can attest to the fact
that consciousness,
that experience,
it requires constant mediation.
We educate ourselves.
We learn about things
that are fascinating.
We create filters for our lives,
information diets, so to speak,
so that we only let in that
which is going to enrich us
and not stay in some
small filter bubble,
but instead constantly
enlarge our filter bubble,
and pay attention
to things that are
going to uplift our imagination.
And so today,
there's a generation
of cultural luminaries or
digital shamans, ecstatic
technicians of the sacred,
as Erik Davis says.
And actually, Erik
Davis is one of them.
Erik Davis wrote
Techgnosis, which
is about the mystical
undertones of technology.
It's a brilliant book with
chapters like The Spiritual
Cyborg and humanity's
desire to conjure up awe
by looking at the
Hubble Space Telescope
as it calls forth
our ever deeper, ever
possible selves in the heavens.
I also like Steven Johnson,
another digital shaman.
He wrote Where Good
Ideas Come From,
The Natural History
of Innovation.
He talks about
creating spaces where
ideas can have sex,
creating spaces
where ideas can intermingle with
one another, mutate, transfuse.
Things can be birthed into
being in these creative spaces,
a brilliant book.
You have Ray Kurzweil, who
wrote The Singularity Is Near,
When Humans Transcend Biology.
How do we use
emerging technologies
that are evolving
exponentially to transcend
all previous limits, and
engineer our own Godhood?
An amazing read.
Ernest Becker, who wrote
The Denial of Death,
distills the human condition
to a series of illusions
that we've programmed
into our consciousness
in order to make sense and imbue
the universe with some kind
of meaning so that
we don't go mad.
Brilliant book.
Alan Harrington, who
calls for the divinization
of the human being, to
literally use technology
to make ourselves gods.
That inspired,
actually, a short film
I made called The
Immortalists on the web.
These thinkers, this Ray
Kurzweil, Erik Davis,
Ernest Becker, pop philosopher
Alain de Botton, these people
are like guides.
They lead the way.
They offer a unique perspective.
And we need to pay attention
to thinkers like these.
We need to celebrate
thinkers like these.
Because these guys, these guys
are ideas worth spreading.
These guys are what the
TED Conference celebrates,
that brilliant institution
that pushes forth
ideas that challenge,
enrich, and enlarge us.